the long-awaited friends the reunion
special is
finally here i'm really excited and
because we couldn't
be more excited i'm gonna show you how
to throw a last-minute watch party for
all of your friends
ooh that's interesting first up
the menu six dishes inspired by monica
rachel
phoebe chandler ross and joey that
requires
little to no time in the kitchen
starting with monica's lasagna
and monica sends her love along with
this lasagna bake a pre-made frozen
lasagna from the store
cut it into squares and serve in small
ramekins
next up phoebe's cookies my grandmother
said she got the recipe from her
grandmother
nestle yeah you know the ones
nestle toll house skip the recipe
put your favorite store-bought chocolate
chip cookies on a plate and call it a
day
next up rachel's infamous english trifle
raspberries more ladyfingers than beef
sauteed with peas and onions
instead of making one large trifle use
drinking glasses to create
mini ones layer ladyfingers jam custard
raspberries and to fake that layer of
sauteed beef with peas and onions
it tastes like feet crumble up some
chocolate wafers and sprinkle in some
green candies
then top with bananas and whipped cream
what's not to like
custard good jam good meat
good speaking of joey and meat
this place makes the best sandwich in
the world
hey joe does it have meatballs on it oh
yeah yeah does it have melted cheese and
marinara sauce
yup make joe's meatball sub sliders
using store-bought meatballs dipped in
marinara sauce
served on a dinner roll topped with some
mozzarella cheese
how good is that oh wow as for chandler
you know it's all about the mac and
cheese i was wondering if you could make
me some of that righteous mac and cheese
like last year
buy some mac from the frozen section
heat it up and dish into individual
bowls for your guests
and to drink ross's margaritas i'm gonna
go make a picture of margaritas
mix one ounce lime juice one ounce water
two ounces tequila and one ounce agave
over ice
and serve got plenty of margaritas it's
all good
decorate your party like thieves with
cups
lots and lots of cups check it out
a cup hat cup banner cup chandelier and
the thing that started it all
the cup now when it comes to the dress
code
have your friends come dressed as their
favorite character
you didn't dress up either yes i did i'm
chandler
need a little inspo channel your inner
monika in barbados
i think that may have missed the table
all you'll need is a backwards cap
a ping-pong paddle and some big hair
your hair is inexplicable or dress up as
joey and the one where no one's ready
you hide my clothes i'm wearing
everything you own
just put on a ton of layers and you'll
be good to go
look at me i'm chandler could i be
wearing any more clothes
you could also go as ross what are you
supposed to be remember the russian
satellite
sputnik hey all right ross came as duty
just rock head to toe brown roll
aluminum foil into antenna
and stick them into a colander hat and
boom
spudnik wow i don't have the worst
costume anymore
and to keep your guests entertained
before the big reunion
wouldn't it be great if we could go for
like two straight hours without dropping
it
yeah it would play the ball game just
make sure you don't hand it off to any
droppers
let me in no no no don't do it
he's a dropper